Kylie Jenner's clapping back you're
always gonna have haters and negative
comments so we try not to read them well
the mom of two is reading some criticism
about new post of her son be nice to
everybody after Kylie shared those pics
of her baby boy a Creator made this Tick
Tock I'm getting ready
which has since gone viral with 3.6
million views and Counting
[Music]
follow me
cause it feels so
Don't Stop Me it accuses the beauty
Mogul of sharing a rare Glimpse at her
son as part of some concentrated effort
by her famous fam to divert attention
away from Balenciaga amid the luxury
Brand's recent Scandal it's just so
crazy the company ignited backlash after
they released promotional materials
featuring kids holding teddy bear
handbags in bondage gear and photos
including paperwork about child
pornography laws I'd say my recent love
for Balenciaga
was through Kanye Kylie's big sis Kim
Kardashian serves as an ambassador for
the brand but Kylie says despite all the
speculation her posting pics is not part
of some Kris Jenner planned plot to
distract from the controversy I think
that things get over analyzed and
misconstrued and you kind of just have
to accept that I think that I have
probably the toughest skin on the planet
because millions of people have said
things about me decided who I am that's
not even me it's hard to like just
swallow that she fired back in the
comments section of that Tick Tock with
quote uh why would I post my child to
cover up for Balenciaga this is why I
don't do this always something to say
there's just people that are always
going to come and say mean comments the
more people who love you the more people
they're going to be there's going to be
who hate you this comes just days after
Kim spoke out against the controversial
campaign she shared a lengthy statement
reading in part quote I am currently
reevaluating my relationship with the
brand basing it off their willingness to
accept accountability for something that
should have never happened to begin with
the reality star admitted she didn't
respond to the controversy immediately
because she was quote disgusted and
quote outraged and has been quote shaken
by the disturbing images adding that any
attempts to normalize child abuse should
have quote no place in our society
period soon after the fashion house
addressed in a statement of its own
quote we strongly condemn child abuse it
was never our intent to include it in
our narrative it admitted that the BDSM
themed campaign was quote the wrong
choice but added that third party supply
the child pornography related legal
documents for the ad Balenciaga is
claiming it since filed a complaint
against those collaborators for quote
Reckless negligence
adding that the company is taking full
accountability for its lack of oversight
and plan to lay groundwork with
organization to specialize in child
protection